frapper les militants de dernière
rénovation alors moi au départ dernière
rénovation je croyais que c'était des
gars que tu appelais pour dans le BTP en
fait ils sont dans la peinture mais
c'est pas le même délire ils font des
coups d'éclats dans la rue c'est ce
collectif qui a l'habitude d'Asperger et
ministère de peinture de bloquer le
périphérique avec pour objectif de
dénoncer l'inaction climatique du
gouvernement et ce matin aux alentours
de 11h 6 militants asperger toute la
place Bovo de peinture orange la place
bobo c'est à Paris et c'est elle qui
sépare le ministère de l'Intérieur de
l'Élysée donc là tu as le ministère
intérieur la stabiliser et là tu peux
pas passer et quand je veux faire des
courses je suis obligé de faire tout le
tour
donc ça me dérange oui ça me dérange
alors les militants étaient donc à deux
pas de l'entrée du palais de l'Elysée on
regarde ce qui s'est passé cette vidéo a
été vu énormément de fois un des
millions de vues pour cette vidéo dans
un instant ils seront là Catalina et
Cyril de militants du collectif
d'ailleurs merci à eux de venir parce
qu'ils savent que c'est jamais simple
voilà et ils viennent ils ont le courage
de venir donc ça bravo à eux et on aura
bien sûr notre BMX ce soir notre brigade
de répression de l'info c'est Eric
Naulleau il sera pas accompagné
également que ce soit mais de Karim
Zeribi le retour de mon caribus c'est
parti
[Musique]
voilà c'est pas le MoDem qui a été élu à
l'Elysée non c'est bien Catalina et
Cyril porte-parole de dernière
innovation merci d'être là en tout cas
merci à vous donner d'être là parce que
c'est courageux chaque fois de venir
parce que c'est pas évident voilà et
souvent et voilà vous faites un petit
peu tomber dessus donc merci à vous
d'être là et même si il y a beaucoup de
gens qui sont contre vous et même moi
c'est vrai que parfois je suis dur avec
vous on sait que c'est quand même pour
la bonne cause mais après on dit est-ce
que voilà c'est la bonne manière de
faire avancer les choses on va en parler
dans un instant c'était l'action coup de
poing de la rentrée ça tout à fait vous
l'aviez prévu quand
révèle pas les secrets de cuisine ah
d'accord comment vous choisissez comme
ça vous dites là ça y est on a fait les
ministères parce qu'on va voir là il y a
une compile de ministère aspergé vous
allez voir comment vous dites là on va
aller entre la place bon on va les
places bobo entre l'Élysée et le
ministère de l'intérieur on va voir ce
que vous aviez fait déjà avant regarder
en attendant
s'il vous plaît
qui est coupable le gouvernement est
clairement hors la loi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ça c'était vos actions donc là
vous avez décidé donc d'aller entre
placebo donc entre le ministère de
l'Intérieur et l'Elysée comme vous avez
pris la décision le 10 et là ça y est il
faut taper plus fort
ouais bah c'est ça là on sait déjà on a
déjà pris pour cible certains ministères
depuis le début de l'année et vu que le
gouvernement nous écoute toujours pas
bah oui on a décidé d'augmenter le
niveau il fallait compléter la
collection on n'est pas encore fait
l'Élysée c'était assez chaud honnêtement
et ça c'est fait et je pense que ça
plutôt bien fonctionné parce qu'on est
là ce soir c'est ça donc vous c'est
essayer de faire parler de vous le plus
possible c'est ça on va voir vous aviez
fait aussi Emmanuel Macron en février
dernier au ministère de l'Agriculture
qui a été interpellé par des militants
de dernière rénovation regardez
[Musique]
je veux plus demander gentiment c'est ma
vie qui sont en jeu on peut plus
demander gentiment monsieur entendez ça
sinon ça va être terrible ce qui se
passe tous les rapports scientifiques
vous le disent pourquoi vous ne les
écoutez pas pourquoi pourquoi
les routes ça a donné lieu à des scènes
assez épiques regardez
énormément
[Musique]
à comment faire
alors
Éric Naulleau
ils vont vous répondre bien sûr dans un
instant est-ce que vous êtes
en accord avec cette action encore ou
avec ses actions ou pas du tout c'est à
dire que l'humanité se divise en deux il
fait ce qui placent les lois de la
République au dessus de leur convictions
et il y a ceux qui placent leur
conviction au dessus des lois de la
République alors vous vous êtes dans ce
deuxième cas c'est à dire que la
légalité c'est pas votre affaire seul
compte votre cause alors
c'est très répandu parmi les écologistes
alors il y en a qui comme vous jettent
de la peinture il y en a d'autres qui
arrose de liquide des tableaux de mètres
par exemple il y en a d'autres qui font
des sabotages alors évidemment on va pas
vous mettre en prison pour avoir aspergé
la place bobo mais moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup inquiété dans votre exposé tout
à l'heure c'est si on n'est pas écouté
on ira de plus en plus fort ça c'est la
logique de ce qu'on appelle d'ailleurs
ça a été nommé quand les mots sont
apparaissent c'est qu'il correspondent à
une réalité c'est là est inquiétante on
appelle ça l'écoute terrorisme le
raisonnement que vous suivez c'est celui
des
la légalité on s'en fout il faut
absolument faire des actions qui vont
marquer les esprits et qui vont faire
avancer notre cause donc soyez-en
conscient évidemment que je vais pas
demander que vous alliez en prison pour
ça mais vous êtes engagé dans quelque
chose de très délétère de très nocifs et
vous envoyer un message à des gens qui
sont peut-être moins équilibrés que vous
qui vont dire ah il faut y aller plus en
plus fort la prochaine fois on va s'en
prendre à des personnes et là vous
passerez au terrorisme tout court donc
soyez conscient de ça parce que pour
l'instant vous êtes dans la bonne
conscience du militant mais un jour la
bonne conscience du militant donne des
choses terribles dans la réalité on l'a
vu par le passé et la voix que suivent
les écolos en ce moment est extrêmement
inquiétante Karim
non moi je pense qu'il faut raisons
garder les mots du sens je me comparerai
pas votre action à une action terroriste
je dirais plutôt que je marque des
regrets vis-à-vis de la manière dont
vous fonctionner je marque des regrets
parce que entre les causes que vous
défendez et les méthodes que vous
employez je trouve que au final vous
gâchez tout les causes que vous défendez
elles peuvent avoir une dimension de
noblesse lutter contre la bétonisation
être pour la rénovation thermique
d'autres moments écologistes pour la
bouffe plus saine une agriculture ça me
pesticide de l'eau bien commun de
l'humanité tout ça c'est entendable et
on peut fédérer autour de ces sujets là
mais on peut pas fédérer avec les
méthodes que vous employez au contraire
de que je crois que vous faites en sorte
vous êtes 140000 à peu près de militants
donc dans les mouvements que vous
représentez vous devrez 10 millions si
vous n'êtes pas 10 millions il faut vous
interroger c'est parce que l'action que
vous proposez est une action qui n'est
pas considérée comme suffisamment
démocratique convaincante au sens
argumentaire du terme républicain au
sens du terme des règles de vivre
ensemble on peut pas faire tout et
n'importe quoi donc là vous donnez le
sentiment d'utiliser non pas des
méthodes de terrorisme parce que le
terrorisme on a été marqué au cœur par
le terrorisme on peut pas faire ce type
de compte par exemple je vous comparer
plus tôt au black bloc qui cherche à
confrontation donc un peu les Black
Blocs de l'écologie donc et moi ça me
dérange parce qu'encore une fois je suis
sensible cause que vous seriez
susceptible de défendre mais je suis pas
du tout en phase avec les méthodes que
vous utilisez changer de méthode vous
fédérer vous emmènerez avec vous en
étant une démocratie présentez-vous
élections distribuer des tracts soyez
convaincants là on vous invite à la télé
dites quel est votre cause et emmenez
les gens positivement pas par les
actions plus de points pas par la
violence la liberté d'expression c'est
pas la liberté de mener des actions de
violence Guillaume moi il y a deux
choses qui m'exaspère un peu d'abord
c'est la méthode je trouve que jeter de
la peinture c'est pas un argument ça
veut rien dire et la deuxième chose
c'est le côté très moralisateur c'est
que vous embêtez beaucoup de gens vous
emmerdez beaucoup de gens vous bloquez
la circulation et moi je me demande si
vous personnellement vous êtes
irréprochable dans votre vie est-ce que
vous ne prenez jamais l'avion est-ce que
vous ne prenez pas la voiture pourquoi
vous êtes venus en taxi par exemple
aujourd'hui dans l'émission et c'est ça
qu'on a envie de vous demander là
taxi dans l'émission
à laquelle vous voulez répondre
en fait vous utilisez le terme de cause
depuis tout à l'heure et malheureusement
c'est pas une histoire de cause
exactement on défend nos vies en fait
enfin moi ma vie elle est en danger à
cause du changement climatique la vie de
vos enfants elle est en danger et
j'essaye pas de vous convaincrement en
fait moi je veux parler aux parents
au 2 millions de personnes qui nous
regardent on est du même côté que en
fait et nous on appelle vraiment tous
tous celles et ceux qu'ils peuvent
entrer en résistance civile parce que
c'est vos vies qui sont en jeu
c'est vraiment enfin c'est vraiment pas
une cause en fait et si on avait le luxe
d'utiliser d'autres méthodes enfin bien
sûr quand les utiliserait ça fait 30 ans
que ils font des que nos ancêtres écolos
font des marches des pétitions qu'on
vote il se passe rien enfin là vous
voyez bien ce qui se passe là le
représenté par
ce truc c'est ça je trouve que vous êtes
par les écoles excusez-moi je vous
entends parler j'ai pas l'impression que
les dirigeants écologistes
soient aussi à l'armée que vous et aussi
alarmant et qui bouge autant que vous
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont plus là
pour faire parler d'eux et pour faire du
buzz que pour faire avancer les choses
oui mais je trouve que vous n'êtes vous
êtes mal représenté c'est pas une
question de représentation politique de
c'est une question de citoyens et de
citoyennes d'êtres humains qui se
préoccupe de leur vie en fait moi je
m'en fiche presque des des représentants
la question c'est est-ce que moi je
devrais pas
comment se fait-il que si la situation
est aussi terrible que vous dites et
nous sommes presque tous à partager
votre opinion les écolos fassent aussi
peu de voix dans les élections parce que
ils portent un mauvais message parce que
les écolossés des gens qui aspergent de
la peinture c'est des gens qui veulent
interdire les arbres de Noël qui veulent
interdire le tour de Monsieur c'est à
chaque fois par les gens
je finis des gens négatifs vous envoyez
des messages négatifs en état et après
vous vous étonnez que les gens
n'adhèrent pas à votre cause mais ça
peut pas marcher que ça soit vos
représentants ou vous c'est la loi de
l'emmerdement maximal essayez de
présenter des choses qu'on essaie
d'emmerder un maximum là c'est le
gouvernement là on a même ce sera
quelqu'un à l'Elysée là on a pas bloqué
une route on n'a pas bloqué nos
concitoyens
et là on a parlé des écolos mais
actuellement le président de la
République c'est Macron
bien clair donc là vous parlez de vote
ah oui mais vous me parlez des écolos
on a parlé des pétitions on a parlé du
vote tout ça c'est très bien moi je l'ai
fait je pense que Catalina aussi tous
les gens ces dernières rénovation aussi
moi j'ai commencé par les marches pour
le climat en 2019 j'ai 19 ans c'était
pas là j'ai vraiment tout fait
la démocratie
d'abord mais moi je comprends pas Eric
notamment ni même Karim ce sont mes
héros ce sont des héros là vous êtes en
train de critiquer des héros là on est
en train de tuer la planète eux veulent
la sauver et pour les critiquer parce
qu'ils mettent de la peinture orange sur
trois grilles mais ce sont des modèles
moi quand il bloque les routes
j'applaudis si jamais bloquait conduire
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont gagné aujourd'hui
ils ont dit vous avez vu on bloque plus
les routes oui on s'attaque parce qu'il
y a plein de gens aussi qui l'ont dit
arrêtez de vous attaquer aux personnes
qui n'ont rien à voir là-dedans et
attaquez-vous vraiment au gouvernement
et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait là c'est
vrai que voilà bloquer les routes moi je
trouvais ça excusez-moi je trouvais ça
ça pénaliser des gens qui n'avaient rien
à voir dans l'histoire Delphine moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec Gilles et
je vous soutiens totalement et Eric
pardon mais le climat c'est pas des
valeurs c'est pas un combat c'est pas
une lubie en fait tout simplement c'est
ça nous concerne tous alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui les écolos font
tellement peu de voix parce que on a
encore l'ancienne image quand on disait
ah bah tu es écolo c'est comme tu es
intello tu es écolo en fait être trop
bon c'est être un peu con en fait
c'était pas la mode d'être nié écolo et
intello limite c'est une insulte non
mais non mais en fait c'est la même
chose aujourd'hui il y a une prise de
conscience à avoir malheureusement on en
parle que quand il y a des choses comme
ça donc merci de d'avoir fait ça et en
fait il y a y a quand même quelque chose
qu'on ne relève pas c'est que vous
l'avez dit le la justice française
condamne aujourd'hui les condamné en
fait le gouvernement français de 19 à 28
ans doivent payer près de 35000 euros de
dommages d'intérêt au conseil
départemental d'Indre-et-Loire et à la
métropole des sources pour le nettoyage
des dégâts causés par exemple c'est
condamné la France les gouvernements
français est pour inaction climatique
donc ils ne sont pas hors la loi parce
que là tu dis carrément que ce sont des
terroristes c'est très grave ce que tu
dis puisque le gouvernement pour une
action
on utilise pas des gens qui veulent
sauver la planète et le mot terrorisme
dans la même phrase parce que je sais
que vous parlez très bien ici donc je me
permets en fait de dire que il faut
faire attention aux mots
encore
juste un excuse pas tout mais tu as
raison évidemment moi j'étais la
première à dire que c'était complètement
con d'aller sur dans les musées ou sur
la route mais en revanche force de
constater force et de constater que
depuis qu'ils font ces actions et et en
Europe dans le monde et dans le monde
entier on en parle et que c'est un sujet
qui est devenu un vrai sujet dans les
médias sociaux
il y avait il y a un an et demi je suis
désolé les annonces de bornes dit à
trois mois elle serait jamais arrivée
l'année dernière avant qu'on casse les
couilles de tout le monde et pour pour
se battre
je trouve que il y a un problème dans
les actions que ce soit celle là ou
celle qui consiste à piétiner des
potagers moi je suis extrêmement choqué
par ça j'ai toujours été très écolo et
mais je suis absolument sidéré des
actions qui sont menées parce que je
trouve que ce qu'on retient
d'aujourd'hui c'est juste de la peinture
rouge c'est un problème avec avec
l'Elysée vous faites rien avancer en
fait il y a attendez à tout le monde
il faut lancer un grand plan Marshall en
France il faut équiper tous les
bâtiments de panneaux photovoltaïques
non mais si et il faut le faire
gratuitement ayez un discours clair qui
fasse que à la fin de la journée tout le
monde soit d'accord avec vous là je sais
pas ce qu'on retient et moi c'est ça
tous les experts et la dernière chose
pardon c'est que je pense que les écolos
font pas leur job la raison Cyril c'est
le problème fondamental
je comprends parce que vous vous êtes
dans votre combat et je le comprends
tout à fait mais aujourd'hui vous êtes
très mal représenté je suis désolé et
c'est ça vous fait du mal au
présentation
en interne c'est pas important parce que
là il y aura un soutien de l'opinion qui
sera beaucoup plus large encore
je remets absolument pas en cause votre
sincérité mais vous croyez que nous on
est suffisamment maso toutes les
téléspectateurs nous tous pourquoi vous
nous fédérerez pas pourquoi on n'a pas
envie d'aller derrière vous en fait
qu'est-ce que vous voulez en fait on
comprend ce que vous dites mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez est-ce que
vous voulez vous représenter est-ce que
vous voulez la révolution est-ce que
vous voulez des élections est-ce que
vous voulez faire un pas qu'est-ce que
vous voulez en recherche à mettre un
maximum de pression sur le gouvernement
et en fait ça marche vous me dites
depuis tout à l'heure que ça sert à rien
que ça marche pas mais c'est faux ça
marche donc quand on a commencé il y a
un an qu'on a commencé
et là on va lancer une cinquième vague
d'action on va peut-être dépasser les
1000 participants on sait pas c'est en
train d'augmenter on commence à avoir
une exponentielle en terme de résultats
contre le climatisme ça commence
toujours petit et ça grandit et puis on
a déjà et puis monsieur vous ne voulez
pas une élection vous me révolution
pourquoi pas mais la révolution ça n'a
jamais existé
une bonne chose une révolution non
violente c'est de ça quand on a besoin
pourquoi pas ça peut attends vous
n'aurez pas réglé le problème de la
représentation ça ne marchera pas
exactement demander
à quelqu'un dans la rue qu'est-ce
qu'évoque pour vous l'écologie je parle
de l'écologie politique parce par la
cause que vous représentez ils vont vous
dire des conneries sur le barbecue
Sandrine Rousseau évidemment ils vont
vous dire Médine aux universités de LV
ils vont vous dire des actions violentes
et illégates il va y avoir que des
choses négatives vous vous en rajoutez
encore une et quand on vous interroge
là-dessus vous dites la représentation
c'est pas mon problème dans une
démocratie la représentation c'est tout
alors évidemment on peut mettre chacun
participe la vie politique et nous c'est
à ça qu'on a pas qu'on invite les
personnes c'est à se rappeler qu'elles
ont un pouvoir d'agir et que ça se
limite pas à voter toutes les 5 ans en
fait ils ont du pouvoir tous les jours
on a tous le pouvoir de construire le
monde qu'on veut un monde dans lequel
vos enfants ils pourraient pas crever la
bouche ouverte dans 30 ans
parce que c'est dur d'entendre de notre
maison
la réalité c'est que quand je vous vois
quand je vois les images là j'ai
l'impression que c'est mon ami Messmer
qui vous avez hypnotisé quand il vous
tire comme ça et c'est une bande de
fanatique pour moi et du coup même si je
suis d'accord avec vous
mais ça ne rend pas compte
mais il a tout été sur nous je suis
d'accord avec vous en fait mais sauf que
ça me fait peur en fait
avec vous pourquoi dégrader des
bâtiments publics on peut chez on va
parler il y a aussi une empreinte
carbone pour nettoyer pour faire tout ce
que vous avez fait avec la peinture tu
peux faire de la plomberie aussi voilà
exactement je peux tout faire c'est la
semaine prochaine non mais la réalité
c'est que le temps qu'on aura un écolo
ça veut dire que les autres ne s'en
partent pas cette question exactement
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a malaise
l'écologie ça doit être dans la culture
politique de chacun qu'on soit de droite
de gauche ou du centre or aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas le cas on n'a pas besoin d'un
parti spécifiquement écolo cette partie
devait être traitée dans tous les
programmes logiquement et tant qu'on
sera dans cette situation on aura un
malaise c'est pour ça et puis ça devrait
être traité au sein de gouvernements et
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont là pour mettre
la pression et quand excuse-moi Alex tu
dis que ces gens-là sont hypnotisés à la
Messmer et toi tu parles de diktat du
mot dictature mais c'est très grave mais
c'est très grave mais pourquoi que
l'écologie doit être en mode punitif
mais pas du tout mais là vous êtes à
l'envers et c'est bien parce que vous
pensez comme ça qu'on va droit dans le
mur vous pensez qu'à vous vous pensez
pas à vous entendre
mais la méthode ne respecte pas le code
ne peut pas mâcher l'attraction sur le
gouvernement point final et le
gouvernement nous donnerons nous donnera
des des directives que nous citoyens on
pourra bêtement appliquer parce que
c'est pas la
je vais interroger le plus écolo d'entre
nous c'est vrai j'ai vu que le cul dans
une bassine tous l'été c'est vraiment
moi je suis le moins écolo de tous parce
que je roule entre 80 et 100000 km par
an donc je suis le moins écolo sur le
plateau moi je ne dis pas comme Gilles
il faut faire comme vous et il conduit
pas donc c'est normal quand quelqu'un
s'allonge sur une route ça le dérange
pas puisqu'il y passe sur la route et je
vais vous dire si encore vous m'avez
vous avez un argument pour me dire la
France ne fait rien mais la France a
fermé des villes si vous avez une
voiture de plus de 10-15 ans des gens
qui ont des voitures de plus 10-15 ans
peuvent plus rentrer dans des villes
c'est une discrimination incroyable ça
veut dire que si tu as de l'argent et tu
as une grosse berline qui est critère 1
électrique partout si tu as pas d'argent
tu as pas le droit de te balader partout
la France elle bouge on éteint les
lumières la nuit dans les villes ça
devient dangereux on nous dit de mettre
les appartements à 19 degrés il y a pas
de problème vous me dites c'est il y a
un an il y a pas un an c'est Corinne
Lepage bon à l'époque avait mis des
pastilles vertes sur les voitures
Corinne le passe moi je suis écolo
j'essaye d'être écolo le plus possible
mais vous avez pas l'impression de nous
emmerder quand même parce qu'on
représente 1% de la population de peau
de pollution dans le monde 1% et vous
dites faut bouger il faut faire des
trucs est-ce que la France ne bouge pas
pour l'écologie on nous dit d'acheter
des voitures électriques de merde qui
tombe en panne toutes les deux minutes
ça vaut 40 000 €. tu habites au 14e
étage faut une prise pour aller la
brancher en bas comment pas faire c'est
pas la pression de faire chier le monde
un petit peu on avance le plastique
l'emballage on fait plein de trucs on
taxe les Français tu achètes un SUV les
pailles j'ai l'impression j'ai
l'impression
c'est vrai et pas écolo ça c'est
horrible [__] monospace parce que si
tu achètes un monospace on va taxer
parce qu'il est trop lourd tu as raison
ta faute tu achètes une autre voiture
s'il y avait rien de fait s'il y avait
rien de fait je serai là en train de
vous dire vous avez raison mais la
France elle est en train de taxer par
rapport aux autres pays dans le monde on
est taxés mais laisse tomber comment on
est accès avec l'écologie vous êtes
venus comment vous avez pas répondu à
Guillaume en vélo vous êtes d'accord
[Musique]
et quand même 70 % qui veulent que vous
soyez sanctionné 21 ans parce que moi
non plus et on se soumet à la justice et
on se présente pourquoi des mines de
charbon en Allemagne
on se présente devant toutes les
commissions bancaire avec vous moi je
trouve qu'elle est très gentil qu'elle a
été moins moins bien
et pas parce que l'autre il a pas de
voiture électrique des gens qui crèvent
de faim ils arrivent pas se nourrir qui
paye pas leur loyer c'est si vous voulez
la France a été gentille avec vous alors
on se retrouve une autre action et
quelque chose